some people they just got fired
and they have no idea why some people
were detained
losing access to health care how many
have been detained
as prisoners in their own country how
many have denied pensions
how many have lost their job this is a
day of national shame
the winter scandal almost embodies in a
way for some people how that people are
seen and treated in the uk because it's
this example where people who did all
the right things suddenly had
a huge amount of their rights and their
access to things that they'd always
taken to granted just taken away from
them without any real explanation
it really becomes this question of was
that just something that was
a series of really really unfortunate
mistakes or is there something at play
where it is because
the vast majority of the words
generation is black
the motherland that's what britain was
called the motherland
and then the mama just rejected their
children for what reason
we didn't do anything wrong
[Music]
foreign 400 happy jamaicans
they've come to seek work in britain and
are ready and willing to do any kind of
job that will help the motherland along
the road to prosperity so the empire
windrush was a ship that actually came
to england in 1948 and most of its
passengers were from the caribbean
and they were all coming to england to
live and work across the uk
and it's become synonymous with an
entire generation of people that came
over about 25 years
because it was people who came from at
the time what was
colonies in the british empire to the uk
to live in england
as citizens of that empire
the windrush generation embodies a
pivotal moment in british history
their arrival would set a new course for
the nation toward multiculturalism
but to better understand issues around
race today we have to look to britain's
past
specifically the british empire
in the 1600s england colonised much of
what is now
places like jamaica and um for over
hundreds of years developed this trade
network which involved
taking millions of people from africa
and
then taking them to the caribbean and
then forcing them to work on slave
plantations where
conditions were horrific but it was a
crucial part
of the british empire's economy when
british slavery ended in the 1830s
there was no real investment in the
colonised countries
the formerly enslaved africans who lived
in these colonies
essentially became british citizens and
began to migrate around the empire to
find work
around the beginning of the 20th century
the united kingdom began to restrict its
immigration policies
severely impacting how many people
outside britain could earn
but when the motherland needed labor it
put out a call for workers
britain needed people to rebuild after
world war ii after being decimated
they're all full of hope for the future
so let's make them very welcome as they
begin their new life over here
hundreds of thousands of people would
come from former british colonies
to the uk and that seems like a
reasonable step to take because they
were part of this
global empire and because they had this
connection to
to england when the empire windrush
arrived i think a calypso singer was
asked to sing the song which was like
london is the place for me london is the
place for me
[Music]
london this lovely city
and it was about the beauty of the city
and about
there and just the excitement of being
in london now the end of their journey
is near
what will they find in the land they
regard as an el dorado
but then the experiences of some people
obviously wasn't great
some white people refused to work
besides black people
some people were refused jobs some
people were sent to live in
in accommodation that was horrible there
is this big discrepancy between how
people see themselves who are coming
from places like jamaica
to how people saw them coming in
there was a real kind of hostility among
some parts of the population to these
new arrivals and it was in some way
specifically because
they were they were black
my name's glenda caesar i'm a windjash
campaigner stroke victim i came to the
uk
when i was three months old both my
parents are from dominica
mommy and daddy came over in the 60s
and they came over for a better life you
know
they wanted their own home in the
motherland
uh england they were told that the
streets were paved with gold
they respected england england was
everything to them
and how did you find growing up in
london oh i loved it
our house was right in the middle of the
road so
it was so diverse because there was
families from every country we had
indian family
family from pakistan a family from
bangladesh
mauritian saint vincent english scottish
irish it was so diverse
and if anyone had asked you when you
were growing up where you were from what
would you have said
england i'm british i had never been to
dominica
i didn't know something was wrong until
after my mum went to dominica on holiday
and my mom
felt sick out there and i wanted to go
out there and be with my mum
i made an application for um a british
passport
and that's when i found out that they
said
no you're not british if you leave this
country again
you won't be able to come back and i was
just getting told you're not british i
had my youngest son
in 1988 and that's when
i found out that he wasn't british
either
within that time my mum passed away um
yeah and i
i just i couldn't get out there to be
with my mom
we want to ensure that only legal
migrants have access to the labor market
free health services
housing bank accounts and driving
licenses and this is not
just about making the uk a more hostile
place for illegal migrants
it is also about fairness
so in 2012 there's this issue of
immigration coming up again and there's
this real sense that britain doesn't
have control over its borders
the british government enforced an
immigration policy known as the hostile
environment
the message was clear if you're here
illegally
pack your bags and leave but the hostile
environment swept up more than illegal
immigrants
citizens of the british commonwealth
were caught in the dragnet
and it turned their lives upside down
i retired and i took a part-time
position in
2009 and it was
then that it started getting complicated
because the employer wanted
more documentation from me to say that i
was british and i was like well i've got
a work history
um you can go anywhere i've got my
children's birth certificate or british
they're all british you can check
but that wasn't good enough and i got
terminated from my
part-time position as a gp administrator
because i didn't have the right
to work here and that's when i realized
it was really really serious
really serious i got into debt
a lot of debt i nearly lost my home
i was in court many times trying to save
the roof over my head
so i started selling old trainers so
that i wouldn't have to
ask my children to help me financially
you know
top up the gas topper electric i need
some food
and even with my daughter i had to share
her benefits
disability benefits but it it was
embarrassing sometimes because sometimes
you get to position where you want to
buy something you feel oh god i gotta
ask them and they've got
their children to maintain as well my
son got depressed and i got depressed as
well
i started blaming myself and there was a
time where i contemplated um
suicide but in my
head i'm thinking if i do that then
what's going to happen to the grandkids
and then
how's he going to get out the situation
since 1971 it had been uk law that
anyone who'd come from commonwealth
countries before 1973
like glenda's parents from dominica
could stay
but many weren't given documentation to
prove when they had arrived
this hadn't been an issue until the
hostile environment came into effect
to make matters worse the government
department in charge of immigration
destroyed the landing cards of those
that came between 1948
and 1973. those landing cards could have
been used potentially as a way of
the windrush generation proving their
right to be in the country so the fact
is is that we don't actually know how
many people were
caught up in it it's safe to say
thousands but it's sad but some people
have died without us knowing but today
glenda fought for the best part of a
decade to prove she was a citizen
even though in my head i was british i
thought maybe i haven't done enough
is that a smile it is a smile what
happened
i've been they've told me because i came
before 1971
i should get my british citizenship they
called my son's name and said oh no
he's got his citizenship and i burst out
crying because
the journey wasn't about me
it was about my son him him belonging
sorry morning home secretary good
morning
when will your government get a grip on
the windrush crisis the uk government
acknowledged its mistake
and undertook a compensation program for
victims of what became known as the
windrush scandal
there was an opportunity to write the
wrongs done
by past governments and to offer payment
after apologizing to that generation for
what they'd suffered
but the reality was significantly more
complicated
for glenda and so many others like her
the hostile environment wouldn't end
when they got their citizenship
the uk government offered her 22 000
pounds for loss of employment
being detained and impact on life 22
000 for what nearly nine to ten years of
loss of everything no way i was so mad i
i was fuming that didn't even cover my
wages that wouldn't evenly covered
the unemployment benefit if i was
entitled to it for those years
i always say it's like a burglar
burglary in your house and then you have
to go and
beg this burglar to give you back your
stuff on average
people were receiving less than 10 000
pounds as part of as past the payment
um when people have been out of work for
years so imagine how many
how how much money you have lost if you
haven't been able to work for say five
years
there are many that will criticize the
government for how it arrived at the
numbers
that in the tone and in the difficulty
and in the lack of belief of those who
have suffered
in turning the burden on them
to prove that they have been
systemically abused
and then not being satisfied with their
paper trail
or their answers i think
we really learned that neither the
substantive redress
nor its delivery
has been acceptable there continues to
be
major concerns amongst
uh the community of survivors and those
that support them
that the scheme will ever be fit for
purpose
and that's because some of the tweaking
that has happened
hasn't fundamentally altered the fact
that it
is a scheme that remains lacking in
impartiality
and really gives the sense of the
government
marking its own homework now that is a
government
that many will accept
is guilty of institutional racism
and so really justice must not only be
done
but it must be seen to be done
we have set up a unit which is helping
those people to get
the documents that they need they are
british
they are part of us i think you have to
say that actually there's a lot more
lessons to learn
but ultimately we haven't yet as a
society and as a country
said sorry in in really a very
meaningful way
last year after george floyd's murder we
saw protests across the uk which
in a way mirrored the ones that we saw
in the u.s and a big part of that was
about the winter scandal
the scandal will always be an example of
a really just blatant form of
discrimination and of wrongdoing against
people who are almost all black
so it's it's a question of what do you
do with that information do you
incorporate into a larger narrative
around
how black people are treated in this
country or do you treat that as an
isolated incident that is unfortunate
but
it doesn't really engage with race
[Music]
for many the windrush scandal is
symbolic of the uk's track record on
race
during the pandemic 64 percent of
essential health workers who contracted
covert 19
were from black or ethnic minority
backgrounds
and there's a disproportionate number of
black residents in the united kingdom
who've died from coronavirus
inequality permeates british society
there's still this question of why do
white families have nine times
that of a black african family
is it because the black family isn't
trying hard enough is it because there's
a single parent or is it because it's
systematic
feelings at play that
that as i say i think that conversation
is unresolved
[Music]
you